are we eating lunch inside outside oh my
God all of that like I don't want to
complain too much because I'll be poor
yeah but I am hot it feels like my
insides are burning
Pepsi are you taking back yes thank you
oh this is pretty oh nice yeah that's
pretty cool Hi how are you
oh that's cute how about a gaucho moment
I made my own little outfit it's not
that cute you don't like it your booty
Jiggles in it it looks like you have a
you went in your diaper it's hanging
very low
they're all so beautiful this is cute
it's honestly too hot to do anything I
know Pepsi can you help me negotiate
here this is dirty and America when it's
dirty they give you a big discount yeah
big discount I want Porsche's hat I'm
breaking it I saw her coming from
her room oh my God I can't feel my leg
oh God oh God guys
oh my God
I can't feel my legs God guys guys
oh my God wait they just came from my
legs doesn't feel well you want some
water
you gotta lay her down here comes the
medicine oh you have to put it back on
the floor
we have to let you down the floor you
have to lay her down like I said
does anyone have any like sugar or gum
or I don't have anything I only have
booze I know nothing we've got to put
her feet up we gotta put her feet just
keep breathing underwear
it's okay I'll cover you wearing
underwear okay okay
where's the Pepsi Pepsi's here
I don't want to die
oh my God this is so embarrassing oh my
God you're okay
I don't know Candace is attending to her
like a wet nurse
been there done that I also have
diarrhea today I think I'm dehydrated
maybe yeah now she's nasty Leah
[Laughter]
it's not fun and then you wake up it's
very scary if it happens to you when
you're alone yeah I'm good sorry guys
where is the Lord
go home and lay down okay there were two
more things I wanted to buy okay
[Music]
we're coming with the AC for Leah great
okay the list go ready with it yeah okay
please
[Music]
thanks guys have fun at lunch
I don't want to be with these people
anymore I know we're all Fanning
ourselves like don't let me go down lord
don't let me be this one to go down
am I gonna die here waiting my cooches
because poor Leah just goes with like
how she's been this whole time
yes we're ready for the peps please
[Music]
foreign